let's start today with an update on the
russian invasion of ukraine because yeah
there's been less media coverage of this
but that doesn't mean there aren't
newsworthy things happening and it is
going so poorly according to new reports
for russia that there are renewed
questions as to whether putin is quote
doomed which we will get to in a moment
reuters and others but we'll look at a
reuters report uh reporting that russian
troops are fleeing and getting back over
the border into russia
russia has largely ceded its gains near
kharkiv wright's reuters and many of the
withdrawing russian soldiers have exited
ukraine moving over the border back into
russia this is per a senior u.s military
official
as it pulls back the u.s has seen
anecdotal reports of russian forces
abandoning equipment
again disorganized command and control
as mentioned that's been
uh that that's been a hallmark a staple
of russian activity so far
the remarks to pentagon reporters
followed a weekend of rapid gains for
ukrainian forces ukraine's general staff
said its soldiers had recaptured more
than 20 towns and villages in just the
last day
as ukrainian forces swept deeper into
territory seas from fleeing russian
troops now the the big stories here
were of course a war of aggression by
russia that's an accurate and true story
expectations early that this would be a
very easy military win for russia
very quickly that assumption evaporated
however
there was the belief that although on
the one hand the longer it went the
worse it is for russia
that eventually if russia decided to
commit the resources
it would overwhelm ukrainian troops
that's not happening and in fact things
are going in the opposite direction
the us military official reads the same
article was upbeat but cautious when
describing the russian advances it's
clear they're fighting hard
uh ukraine said it repelled attempted
russian advances in two important areas
of the donetsk region the city of bakmut
and mayorsk near the coal producing town
of horlivka the general staff said in an
evening update but the senior u.s
official said russia was still focusing
its firepower on bakmoot so a lot more
tactical information that you can read
if that is interesting to you
now the question becomes what about the
propaganda war and what about the future
of vladimir putin there's an interesting
article in uh the hill
which is worth reading if not
uh it's worth reading let's just put it
that way
and it's it's by alexander motel who's
an opinion contributor and it says like
his soldiers is putin doomed now the
article is somewhat hyperbolic
admittedly and the article writes
vladimir putin is kaput
the proof of that is the below letter
written by a 26 year old soldier in the
russian army vivi tarasenko we know
nothing about tarasenko except he was a
resident of putin's brainchild the
so-called luhansk people's republic and
that he has a wife valeria and a small
son we also know tarasenko died in
battle during the recent ukrainian
offensive in the kharkiv province
ukrainian intel found the letter
um the letter was written with little
punctuation and no capital letters so
the letter reads
this letter is for the future if i
should die or be taken prisoner or
become a vegetable written july 17 2022
it's very hard to write i'm crying but i
must beloved lara tell our son what kind
of dad i was that we were sent as cannon
fodder to zaliman
a village in kharkiv province without
armor without ammunition without normal
weapons this is about our situation when
our son grows up tell him his dad wanted
very much to return home to be the best
dad ever i've been drinking and i'm
writing emotionally i know that this all
will be forgotten and that you will be
living your own life that you'll find a
new husband that'll simply disappear in
the war like all the guys unfortunately
i didn't have a normal life say that dad
was an athlete didn't smoke didn't drink
it's terrible that everyone has
forgotten me it's very hard to accept
all this but all people die and this
cycle can't be changed it's bad to die
in the summer if only i were at the
seashore
and
what is written in this hill article is
that tarasenko's complaints are not
unique
the russian leadership with putin at the
head has evinced a profoundly cavalier
attitude towards lives not just of
innocent ukrainians but also of russian
soldiers and what this article and
others go on to say
is that there is really no path out of
this for putin
that is going to be anything short
of a of a failure and doom for putin now
early there were all of these
speculations is putin sick and has a
death wish and is determined to be
assassinated eventually by uh operatives
from other countries or is putin
so drunk on the idea of reassembling
some version of the ussr that he's not
thinking clearly and
whatever the case may be
i at this point think the ship has sort
of sailed on making rational sense out
of what putin was thinking and when he
was thinking it and what the end goal is
here but it is clear that if there is
going to be a win for russia
it's going to be a win only with
completely revised objectives and so at
this point when this didn't
end in two weeks
we started talking about well it's
likely going to be more than months at
this point and what is the ultimate goal
because a complete and total takeover
takeover of ukraine seems increasingly
unlikely
it seems quite plausible that putin and
his cronies will revise their military
objectives and they will revise them to
say our goal is actually to control a
lot less territory than we initially
planned
with those revised objectives they may
be able to come away with something that
they would call a win for propaganda
purposes but there's also a fear
the fear is
that as russia and putin realize
we're not going to be able to continue
mounting offensives and really take
ukraine in the way that originally some
projected us to do
there's the fear
that an increasingly belligerent putin
will resort to those tactical nuclear
weapons these are sometimes called
battlefield nuclear weapons it's not
like the massive bomb that destroys
entire cities
uh but they are battlefield or tactical
nukes
and that that would be something that
putin is willing to do to kind of
maintain this image of strength the kind
of hair-brained
caricature
of the alpha male that has pervaded the
maga movement in the united states quite
frankly it's sort of a similar dynamic
that is a fear that an increasingly
cornered putin would go in that
direction so it is unpredictable what is
going to happen but what we know is that
it is not going well for russian troops
and there is still an invasion there is
still a war even if more and more
mainstream corporate media isn't talking
about it who doesn't love a good cereal
the crunchiness the sweetness it
satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below